one two three good Monday morning
[Music]
hey everyone how's it going
today I am in Stockholm Sweden with two
very very special guests mpj from fun
fun function and ISA would you like to
do a quick intro on who you are to my
beautiful subscribers I'm mbj I run a
YouTube channel called fun fun function
it's about JavaScript start out being
about functional programming but it's
also about creativity and productivity
and like basically stay and happy and
productive and excited about your work
as a programmer important stuff so I'm
either I do a lot of talks and
conferences around the world so
basically I just talked about like
performance and machine learning and
whatever it is that I'm interested in
learning at the time a few very dear
topics to me is like cultural
programming I think it speaks a lot to
do it channels and optimization and web
performance and how that plays out in
like different societies and different
countries by our data plans aren't
limited and nowadays I work at idle
hands sore from I'm relocated in January
and also working about like how to make
financial and payment systems more
accessible to the masses awesome so I
wanted to interview them to about things
like how they got into tech what are
their challenges that they're facing
right now as well as just some other fun
questions that I've come up with so
let's get started so I thought we said
from the very beginning and I wanted to
know how did you two get into
programming like tell us your journey
new origin story yes I I'm actually like
I actually have a theatre brethren so TV
production but like during my school
years I was really interested in memory
techniques you know like memorizing like
the first hundred digits of pi and like
memorizing the order of a deck of cards
and I just realized that I found a lot
of websites about it and I then realized
that I wanted to create websites about
it and I guess
like this horrible thing called PHP nuke
which was sort of like WordPress but
atrocious and but I learnt it like how
to do like minor modifications on that
and eventually I just like learn that I
oh I really have a have a knack for this
and I really find this really exciting
and fun fun to work with and then I
guess gradually started started doing it
more and then it just like turned into
this thing that I did so did you work as
a software engineer for a little bit and
then you started B you to Chandler or
how did that work yeah after school I
didn't relieve didn't really know what
to do so I started in an e-commerce
company was selling button badges
I basically coded our our e-commerce
system from scratch because like Magento
and stuff like that didn't exist at the
time and that's basically like my
education and programming and after that
that company tanked it turns out I'm
very good at making money not so good at
managing money and I started working as
a consultant which eventually led me to
relocate Stockholm I ended up at working
as a consultant there which I hated and
eventually like jumped around a couple
of times until I ended up at Spotify
worked there for four years and then I
started the channel and then like that
took over in in time and what I needed
to do like ho hey this is big now I need
to decide if I should do this or a
course qualify and you decided that no
the channel is it's the best way for me
to like exploit my skills at the right
time so ISA how did you get into
programming yeah for me it was not
glamorous at all like there wasn't any
deeper meaning you're calling from the
skies and said you know what road but
for me it was more like a parachute kind
of thing hmm
because back in Brazil education is
actually very ironic in the sense
because you have like public and private
usually
privates much better but there are a few
set of schools public ones that are very
good so there was a school that I wanted
to get in for high school and they they
were public and very nice quality but in
order to get it septum into that you had
to do like a technical course as well as
mentally so I managed to get in the
examination and then I had to choose one
thing and back when I me 13 year old me
you had no idea what I even wanted to do
like it was kind of a hard thing to just
ask the child even like a teenager but
within the the set of options that I had
I just chose informatics back then
because oh you know what I spent a lot
of time in the computer perhaps I can do
something with this and I obviously had
no idea what the course even was I never
actually knew a programming was I I just
thought I was gonna you know like fix
some computers or like some title films
I don't know I literally had no idea
turns out I really liked it I I started
learning like C at the time and that was
actually very fun it's just like seeing
all these things happening in the
terminal the black screen and then you
just pop something in the terminal and
things happen like I did dozens of
calculators linked lists so whatnot that
moment the programming is really like
magical when he first first learned like
I almost forgot about that when you use
like chris-craft things and they appear
on screen exactly and I never after that
time is hard to get the same kick if you
got when you were first learning how to
program
but then I I just fell in love with it
so I just followed the whole to your
path they went into your university for
computer science
eventually jumped out because I just
thought that well I really liked the
things that I was studying but that
wasn't it's like I didn't fit in the
whole classroom scenario so I started
working with research at the time so you
must be learning algorithms to predict
text back when the whole iPhone thing
that we have wasn't I think so we use
like Markov chains and a set of other
things to make that happen then migrated
in its back-end sort of learning Java
and all sorts of things and then I just
figured about this whole life what
programming
and then I just really fell in love into
that and just started like building web
systems and web interfaces that's what I
do and so no yeah it was kind of like a
love story but not a very calculator
calculator one right cause you made
calculator let's just let the waves
drown out the death so we talked a
little bit about that first spark that
you get when you first start programming
and everything seems like magic you do
have been coding for a long time now so
I wonder kind of how are the ways that
you found how to rekindle that spark
like after coding for so many years how
do you find that moment again to where
your life this is awesome I just code it
something really cool for me it comes
mostly when I'm like delving into
unknown territory which is like the the
easiest way to get that going or when
you have like for me it comes a lot when
there's like a problem that I at first
have no idea how to solve and then I
just get my head around like knowing all
the tiny details assembling everything
and putting that into a package but I
think most of the the trajectory and the
success of a developer kind of depends
on how to get that spark alive because
otherwise like it just fall into the
trap of knowing exactly where you're
gonna do from the start of the day to
the end you can just basically know oh
this is gonna happen this is gonna
happen I'm gonna tackle this kind of
problem that I already know how to solve
so for me it takes a lot of exercising
and like getting to know new things and
like for example I kind of achieved that
by getting to no closure because it's a
completely functional language I didn't
actually need that for my work but I
just kind of chose to you know what let
me grab this insanely a different way of
thinking about comb that I wasn't at
first used to and that kind of light
laid it up for me because like because
then I can understand that well the the
joy in learning the new things all the
time is still
here and that spark that well I can
think in many different ways it's still
there for me just take something new to
start and explore that yeah I think the
novelty part speaks to me a lot actually
like did we did a completely non
programming thing a couple of months
back where like I wanted like a low
physical habit tracker in order to like
make us like I'm trying to learn
Portuguese and he's are trying to learn
Swedish so I wonder like it's the box
with flip switches that you can track
one for every day you know like and like
nothing electronic about it or anything
just like a little box with click and
that was so fun building yes
reconnecting where like I used to build
a lot of these slow things when I was
when I was a kid but yes like crafting
something that you didn't quite know how
to do where place it was so long since I
did it
but yes yes I figure out like how do you
use a band saw again and like that there
was so much fun I didn't expect to have
that much of a blast building something
that simple but it was just outside of
my normal soul and that just sparks
something interesting in the brain that
kind of speaks to a different thing
which is just to see the result of what
you're building right before your eyes
which for me was the first part like I
was coding on these set of like if Sanel
says and all these like different
commands and just seen it run on the
terminal interacting with me was like
making fire all over it like for me that
was the the effect and then when you
build something that's physical that's
also right there like you you spend like
one two hours building like little parts
and then you just see the whole thing I
love that metaphor of making the of
making fire I don't once loved fire when
I was a kid like I I burned so many
things yeah for sure but it's something
like about the thing where like you
build like the fire you constructed and
then like you set a little spark to it
and then
just like ya it comes to life I love the
way that you two have talked about like
having your curiosity lead you to the
places where you can get that spark
again because we talk a lot about
learning new technologies and how to
stay relevant as a software engineer but
I love that you to have found such an
organic way to do that in a way that
fuel that fuels like who you are as a
software engineer so that you do and
keep enjoying coding but what is your
strategy I think it's something similar
I think about a year ago I did I started
picking up kind of like Arduinos oh yeah
and I'm not like a hardware person I
want I want to so bad do this I'm afraid
of Arduinos how do you push past your
fear
I'm also Scott sitting behind the camera
electrical engineering major ahaha so
when things start working and I'm like
why isn't this like okay but it is
frustrated but it is that like the when
things come alive in a physical space
which is really like an electrical
engineering thing it's so amazing yeah
we're just trying to get like a little
servo motor just like spinning yeah when
it was spinning I'm like all this thing
is doing is spinning it's just
electricity just making the thing spin
exactly yeah I definitely agree with
like just finding new things finding new
technologies that work in different ways
that you're not expecting
and just really like almost getting
obsessed with that problem of getting it
to work in such a small almost makes me
like appreciate the little things in
code where it's like yeah sometimes you
want to make a really big system that's
fancy architecture and other days you
just want a little servo motor yeah I
think there's something to be said about
like that when you say obsession like
sometimes I get it so caught up in like
making meaningful things like thinking
about like how does my work fit into
like the world holistically and then
like it becomes like this almost like
extension list truck yeah
and they just ends up like if you follow
it too far it just becomes depression
and sometimes is very nice to us enjoy
you know a meal or like yeah discussion
or in the present or a you know motor
that's what I mean I think I talked a
lot about on this channel about how to
make an impact as a software engineer
and there are really big impacts that we
can make but at the end of the day like
a lot of the stuff that we do is little
bits of problem solving to get us
exactly and really getting curious about
that problem solving it you can really
kind of lose yourself in a delightful
way which I think all of us as well as
everywhere everyone else out there
really enjoy is that kind of just like I
don't know why I still want to solve
this but I do
[Laughter]
alright so now I'm wondering also like
kind of more on the career perspective
as well as just like what your
day-to-day is like what are some of the
challenges that you're facing now as a
software engineer and inker work yeah I
actually like for me it's been since I'm
doing the YouTube channel full-time now
I'm kind of like finding myself missing
like the the team interactions a lot so
like that and that has been like a
surprising boon quite like living with
you because sometimes either come home
and like it's so frustrated over
something like oh my god this this thing
happen at work and I know I'm gonna like
oh yeah good I hear because I don't get
any of that and like when you're in it
it's like frustrating but like once
you're outside of it it's it's a super
fascinating problem to like see how our
software teams interact and how have the
kind of like the overlap between
software engineers because today
software software is built by such large
teams so that means that like the very
of only like pipes like I don't know
thirty percent of time is spent coding
the rest is spent like in
acting with other programmers and
figuring out how like how to how to
write code together also touches my
biggest challenge which is it's
definitely people like I think after
we've been like a soft engineer for
years and years we kind of learned how
to your way into code right like there's
very few things that are actually
challenging in the technical sense I
mean obviously you're bending if you
depends on what you're building but I
feel like my biggest challenge nowadays
it's just how to get people to
coordinate and everything that revolves
around people because often like
something that you're building that is
like an effort of a whole team not just
of engineers but with designers and
product owners I've won on it's like the
whole challenge is how do you get people
to be on the same page first of all to
communicate needs to feel safe enough to
say hey I have a problem I need help
with it and and that for me is the
biggest challenge of how can I be a part
of something that works better because
the team is just feeling so in sync and
so open and and just can work together
because ultimately like in my company I
said oh like there's so many people from
ridiculously different backgrounds like
I come from Brazil there's people from
Nigeria they're super from Russia and
all these people have like very specific
types of communication and like how do
you put all that together and make
people just understand each other and
not be offended or not be thinking that
they're like being underestimated or and
and that is the most tricky interesting
thing I've ever done so far obviously
building the shade to school and like
playing with stack is nice but
ultimately for me this is like a really
infinitely cool challenge yeah how to
get people to cooperate yeah cuz I feel
like more than finding like the right
technology that's gonna solve all our
problems solving those communication
problems and empathizing and talking
about how you're gonna work together has
a lot more like can provide a lot more
benefits than finding like the right
technology because if you do mesh with
your team well and you figure out how to
communicate with each other well then
there's so much more that you can do and
finding out what to solve how to solve
it in a really good way that accounts
for everybody's opinions and
perspectives you're going to make a
better product it's gonna be more fun
building that way exactly just like a
couple of like examples of things they
can actually solve and do better if you
have like a team that is on the same
page it's like how do you keep code from
being duplicated all the time like
sometimes they don't have people talking
to each other when they're gonna build
something new and there could be
something already made that you could
just like import and extend instead of
just helping to build from scratch again
you can have like people that can read
to you code in a way more efficient way
if they understand where this person's
coming from or if that's a decision that
has been made before by the team or by
something else
and that reminds me of a very
interesting dynamic that I had with a
co-worker not too long ago so basically
we were talking about code and we were
like talking about one of his pr's and I
thought the whole solution was a little
bit over engineered and and then I just
asked okay but why did you decide to do
something this way and he was like well
because of code quality and it was like
aha
what is code quality like this is not
commonplace for everyone and like for
him immense performance for me means
readability so these things they're
never gonna understand and be on the
same page unless you have a full
conversation with people and just unless
they are open to sharing their values
with you that is so interesting I was
I'm reading principles by Ray Dalio and
he is like talking a lot about how
communication and interaction between
people would be so much easier if people
were good at verbalizing and and
communicating their principles to other
people because you could probably have
solved so much of that communication
problem much earlier if you knew where
like the different values are coming
from and and yeah after we had that
discussion like we just fine-tune way
better like I was better at reviewing
his PRS he was better at living mine so
that's something that everybody just
profits from once you get that finally
corrected it reminds me that like I did
this video a while back an exploration
on mano records because what if I moved
from like an extreme multi rifle
approach to a much more monolithic
repository approach during my tenure
there and I was vehemently like on the
multi rifle side and I thought like
after a while I just realized that this
is way better and I realized that the
multi rifle thing is something that
developers often like develop because
they don't want to solve their
communication issues so one of the
comments on my video like what's such a
great example he was like I had this
problem with a co-worker he won't listen
to me at all and I really tried so I
eventually just started my own reco
it was wonderful and I mean like if you
just imagine like what this behavior
creates if you have like an organization
where everybody does this as soon as you
like you find this person that you can't
reach instead of reaching them or like
removing them from the organization if
they can't be reached then that just
means that the constant increase of
people that are bad communicators or
like that they're just chopped off into
different corners of their times by
communication can lead to like 500
different legacies yeah exactly it's
like oh no oh no this depends on library
a and that's maintained by John oh god
let's just fork it yeah so I think that
like it's important than to notice when
you're doing something to hide your
communication issues so yeah I feel like
just working on a team as a software
engineer means there's a lot of
opportunities for conflict yeah and as
humans we want to avoid conflict we also
a water avoid talking about her feelings
and be vulnerable with each other but a
lot of the times this
exactly the work that you need to do in
order to do good work together as a team
oh god yeah I really feel like oh I want
to stay on that for a bit like conflict
as a means to growth because conflict
yes definitely on an uncomfortable thing
but it is also a thing that we need that
we want to seek because if we can find a
way of having like a structured
communication around our conflict
identify our issues and work work it out
that almost always ends up in both
parties becoming much stronger
communicators developers and also a more
well needed tea which I think also
speaks to why is it important to have
people from different backgrounds or
genders or sexual orientation to work
together on a project because like if
you get a bunch of people that just kind
of agrees in the same room well you know
what you're getting but when you have a
lot of people that come from different
places or have different opinions in
general then you're like you're probably
gonna understand a lot of a lot more
about things that you had no idea about
and yeah that's probably gonna come in
with some conflict or some things that
you don't agree at first but if if that
person is not there to like spring my
mind with new ideas and new concepts
then I'm not gonna grow then I'm bound
to be like the same engineer that I was
like for the last five years so that's
not what I'm that's not what makes us
great as engineers and as people I think
it's definitely interesting to have
those conversations and for that to
happen obviously you need to be safe you
need to feel safe in the team and you
need to be confident that your opinion
is gonna be heard and respected even if
like the team doesn't decide to do your
your idea the way that you intended but
in order for for people to share their
minds there needs to be like an
emotional safety in the group and that
comes from communication and then just
be transparent in yeah I really I really
believe it's structured conflict leads
to growth yeah and we we have a little
bit of things in the software industry
around this like we have retrospectives
which is kind of a little bit like that
we said around and then we talked about
positive things and then we
move on to like that there's negative
things and we pick a few of them because
it's like now we're talking about them
in the non you know and we do it in a
way that isn't around blame but how like
we can move forward it's fortified I had
this thing which freaked me out at the
beginning which called incidents
whenever a a bug reached reached a user
that was considered an incident and then
you like had a special meeting for that
and like the destruction like you create
a timeline what could have happened what
like what's and what could we have done
like what were the holes and like what
led up to this and then you had like a
also did like a remedy but they're kind
of like an action plan for like
remedying and making sure that this this
couldn't happen again
and it was very like focused on being
blameless or rather that the team took
blame like nobody was allowed to take
like not a single if a single person
took blame that was considered an error
because like this should never be a
situation where a single person can make
an error on their own that should always
at least be a code review where somebody
else has approved yet yeah and that was
really really good and I think that
developing like communication structures
like that can really help and making
people feel safe and in expressing
expressing themselves and like this is a
problem I'm vulnerable
yeah on the business side it's like risk
mitigation but on a very human side it's
just like having each other's back oh
yeah feeling like integrated into a team
of people that you're there for them and
they're there for you yeah that's true
having people that you can rely on and
that you trust and they trust you to do
what is best at that time and like if
someone fails them like the fact that
someone else can be there to pick you
back up like that's a great way to build
trust and build those relationships okay
so you feel like you're a little bit
safer and you're you're free to make
mistakes basically you do have to make
mistakes in order to grow like that's
like I think the other thing that kind
of goes hand-in-hand with conflict like
a
you're willing to make mistakes and
learn from them and grow from them
otherwise it's it's a lot harder - yeah
all right well we talked about a lot of
great stuff today so thank you so much
mpj and ISA for being on the channel
today I will leave their links to their
stuff in the description box down below
if you like these kinds of interviews
where I talk to other people all around
the world and leave a comment down below
and like and subscribe as always and
[Music]
that is sometimes the thing that you
have to do yes in order to figure out
this is this is divine the scenes are
like shooting next